[Music]
there's been a lot of discussion this
week from members of the new york giants
brain trust about the decision to trade
odell beckham jr to the cleveland browns
earlier this week it was dave gettleman
the general manager of the team engaging
in a media conference call
that
answered a lot of questions although
some of the answers weren't all that
acceptable on wednesday it was pat
shurmur at the ohio state pro day
workout according to paul schwartz the
new york post he was asked about the
decision to trade beckham and shurmur
said he was absolutely behind it of
course what else is the head coach no i
thought it was ridiculous that we traded
this guy what are we doing my general
manager is a buffoon i banged on his
door and said don't do it i tried to
physically restrain him from making the
call to john dorsey to finalize the deal
i threatened to quit and they still did
it i'm not behind it i strenuously
object that would be amazing yeah oh
it'd be great great
entertainment and it would be a heck of
a job for the giants to try to find a
new head coach in late march but you
know the cowboys had to do it and it
kind of worked out for them at least for
one year or two
so
what shermer said ultimately about the
situation
we feel good about what we got we got a
starting safety we got a first round
pick we got a third round pick we felt
it was good for us because we were able
to come to an agreement cleveland
thought it was good for them yeah it's a
win-win right but
very rarely is there a trade where both
sides are thrilled with the outcome and
this is one where we won't know for
several years just like any draft pick
you don't know unless you get a rookie
phenom or a complete and total bust it
takes a while to figure it out and the
thing is by the time those years have
played out because because every year
someone will say to me hey why don't you
go back and grade the drafts from three
years ago here's why i don't do it
because nobody cares right right you
can't get anybody to care about what
happened three years ago because they're
worried about what's going on right now
they're worried about the next draft and
not even last year and last year it's
too early two three years ago no one
wants to do it because no one's gonna
click on it no one's gonna care people
have tried to do it no one cares and
trust me if people cared about it we
would do it and others would do it yeah
right no i i get that uh you know i
think with this whole situation with pat
shurmur odell beckham jr okay i mean
obviously hey pat schumer's an offensive
coach i'm sure he would have loved to
have odell beckham jr in the perfect
world because he's such a weapon but i
think he realized and i'm not sure it's
not best i don't know if pat shurmur's
personality lends him to uh actually
absolutely endear himself to a guy like
odell beckham jr shurmur's kind of plays
it close to the best it's kind of no
nonsense he's not going to crack a whole
lot of smiles or laugh a whole lot of
ways he's a real football coach that way
so
i think he made it did his best to kind
of get a relationship with odell beckham
jr but to me mike just from the outside
looking in and everything you read and
connecting dots it just seemed like it
all went south after the jocena anderson
interview it went from there then to
odell with the injury at the end of the
year and oh could he have maybe played
could he have not in these meaningless
football games and i think that's where
everything got lost between odell the
new york giants and that's when they
probably decided you know what we have
to start thinking about moving this guy
yeah and
look in in hindsight it's not a shock
but it's something they should have done
last year and the one question that
hasn't been answered what could they
have traded him for last year before
they paid him 21.45 million here's my
theory about why we've seen
both guys speak so much this week and
especially the conference call with dave
gettleman i think they tried to get
every question asked and answered before
everybody goes to arizona this weekend
and i think part of it is they're trying
to protect john mara from the onslaught
of questions about what is your plan why
did you do this and i think he's gonna
say well dave addressed it dave
addressed it it gives him cover now so
he doesn't have to answer tough
questions he should have to answer tough
questions because that makes sense what
you're saying but i think that this was
all let's get this out of the way now
right so when john merrill walks into
the lobby of the biltmore and everybody
gathers around him he's going to at
least have something he can point to
other than trying to fumble his way
through answering the questions all
right full hour pft live coming right
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports